so Maisie we're here on the set of up on
the roof tell me what the films about
it's about homeless children and it's
kind of a really raw story about a boy
called Michael who kind of gets himself
into a bit of trouble and a Gokul Trish
she doesn't really help the situation
she's very free and trying to convince
Michael that this there's more to life
than just staying up on this rooftop and
you know he's got so much more to
explore into to live for and I kind of
think she's gives him a kick in the
right direction but maybe you know gets
him into a bit of trouble in the way so
yeah it's exciting what kind of
character is she well I think she likes
a male attention a lot I think and
that's another kind of issue you know
she she messes around with people a
little bit but I think it's because
maybe she's never had a father figure or
you know I think she's there's a lot to
history that you never really get to
hear about and are the sort of questions
that you have at the at the end at the
end of the script I have a lot of
questions I was speaking to
nor the director and just you know I
think it's um yeah there's a lot more to
the story than you first you first see
and enter the characters as well and I
think that's what you know that's why I
liked it at least so how do you get into
a character like that when there's so
much more to kind of know about them
because it's a short film isn't it yeah
I think with the costume and the hair
and the makeup and things it's really I
mean they're all my own clothes but I
never usually wear the weather like this
or and I think you know being here and
being up on the roof in the middle of
London and you know it's it's really
kind of real and I feel like I'm
actually here and and yeah it's a lot of
improvising as well which is nice to
kind of just make it feel more natural
and and yeah really really get into it
and yeah it's just different to what
I've done before I think and I'm you
know looking forward to more characters
that are my age and I think that's
different I'm usually depicted as a
younger person or like a tomboy or
something and this time she's like you
know a real teenager and I think it's
just kind of different and yeah people
get to see a new side to me as well tell
me about working with your co-stars on
the film as well yeah it's really
exciting
Michael is fantastic who plays the
character Marcus and there's a few other
lads here today that I haven't actually
worked with yet we'll be doing those
things later but yeah all fantastic
young actors and it's yeah it's great to
do things like that with people your own
age as well to see you know you can be
working with them again in the future
and this is your sort of generation of
actors growing up and yeah it's really
exciting
I'm very different of course for what we
know you for best I have stock ongoing
with ferns both in terms of the age
you're playing and of course as the type
of the age of the actors you're working
with as well how does it compare then I
think it's kind of different you know
like this is a lot of smaller scale but
somehow no it's it's um a lot more
intimate maybe and there's a lot more
time to just talk to the director and
you know get your head around what's
going on and and I think with Game of
Thrones sometimes a little bit go go go
and it's nice to have you know an idea
of what's going on every second of the
day well this is just completely
different and um you know I still really
love it and to me really it's just about
the story I think and the character and
that doesn't really matter if it's just
a short film or if it's you know Game of
Thrones a hugely successful TV series I
think you kind of just if if I like the
character and I like the script and you
know it's just the experience really I
find so this is you know up there
definitely with my favorite things that
I've done
what made it stand out for you I think
the rawness of the story really like
there's so many questions as I said
earlier I had at the end and you know
it's really kind of hits hard you know
what life is like and but just giving
you like a small snippet it's not like a
big trying on story about you know it
kind of just gives you a little glimpse
into what life is like for these kids
and how you know tricky they find it and
and then you come back out of it again
and you're left like oh but you know
what happens and what happened to her
and him and and yeah I just I I was you
know flipping the page it's I was with
my friends and one was like all you need
to need to read the script
my agent really really liked it that's
all okay and I was all my friends around
and they're like amazed you stop reading
so going on your emails I was like but
mom I can't start reading this so yeah I
just you know it's different or how I've
reacted to other scripts now of course
she's lived in a different world
- I estar but I stalk also has her
any problems essentially right from
beginning and Game of Thrones it had
quite a journey in season 3 haven't you
how have you found it and what stood out
for you oh I think this year there was
um I mean a lot happened to Arya in
season 2 and in season 1 but I think
this year we picked up again re is
meeting lots of new characters and
although I had a fantastic year in
season 2 she just stayed in Harrenhal
but she got captured seen her haul left
Harrenhal this year she's been on the
run she's got taken by the Brotherhood
we've now seen and leave the Brotherhood
I think it's just you know it's a lot
more a lot faster paced and it was great
working with so many different actors
and I think that's what I like about
areas every season is different you know
you never really know what's happening I
know this is books that you can go by
but still those little changes here and
there and I've really really enjoyed
season 3 it was my favorite so far to
film I had a great time with all the
other actors and yeah it was just I feel
like I'm growing up now and this kind of
like getting more used to it and come on
to set and know everybody and the
directors and things and it just you
know really felt like you know something
I could see myself in the future doing
this sort of thing it was the first time
that's kind of happened really I usually
just sort of think oh I'm gonna go away
and do this filming thing now and then
I'll go back to school you know but it
was really felt like I was part of it
which is nice so nice to hear where
would you like to see her going in
future because I guess there's so many
options for her yeah I think well
there's this I'm not gonna give any
spoilers for the book um but yeah I said
I've always seen Arya is kind of being
on our own in the end like I mean be
grateful to get back to your family and
acknowledge them and like yeah you know
mum I'm safe you know but I think I
don't know she's one of the only
characters that could really do it alone
you know a lot a lot of the characters
need their army or you know their
dragons or you know Joffrey isn't really
anything without Cersei and it's kind of
everybody needs their other people and
Arya is possibly you know fine on her
own if not stronger I think she could
yeah kick ass on her own so that's kind
of a good quality to have seeing as
everybody else is usually you know
against you and you can't really trust
anyone so yeah I think you'd do well on
their own in
and actually you mention kicking a stone
she's a real kick-ass character since
she and it kind of got me thinking
another really kick-ass character is a
hit girl in the movie kick-ass what do
you think it'd be like if those two
teamed up I think that would be amazing
you know like well I think I was
watching it was just bringing out on
number two right and I was watching all
the trailers and it's just all the
combat work that Chloe Moretz does and I
think I met her stunt double as well and
I just you know it's really cool but
it's kind of different because it's
modern-day and stuff but I think they're
kind of the same character but
present-day and medieval time but yeah
it's it's great all these strong female
characters that are coming out at the
moment and um it's very different you
know these young girls kind of you know
fighting and it's it's different to what
we've seen before and I'm I kind of like
the way it's going and I get a lot of
sort of fierce young girls coming up in
other scripts and things this definitely
something that I am you know I want to
be a part of you know this new thing
that's coming up now you mentioned
stunts and fighting and stuff that maybe
think of all your sword fighting skills
in Game of Thrones of course how did it
how is it training to do that did you a
dance background help with the
choreography for that yeah definitely I
we kind of just learn a routine and then
you put it together with the stunt guys
so if you hit them it's okay because
they've got iPads on things and then you
go on with the other actor and so hold
it you know sort out any issues that you
have with each other or and you
basically find difficult and then you go
ahead and film it but yeah I think when
I first started I'd never done sold
fighting before and Arya in the books is
left-handed and I'm actually
right-handed so I decided to try it
left-handed which was a bit of a silly
decision I realize now by the time I was
like yeah this is gonna be great and I'm
like why did you do that I stuck to it
now and it's fine you know it just would
have been easier like if I'm really
struggling with a move I'm like put it
in my right hand and do it with use and
I'm like you know this could be so much
quicker but it's a challenge and I like
that and um you know you're not every
day that you can sort of fight with your
other hand
um in the future if I get any other
left-handed characters come up I can I
can give a go so yeah it's it's
definitely helped me and not hindered me
but it would be easier some days and you
believe you were doing some fencing as
well and a background to help yourself
yeah I said like a beginner's course so
now I can go to any fencing lessons and
they'll take me in because I've done my
my beginners bit but yeah it was kind of
different because the guy that I was
working with he kind of thought I was
mad and again I said well I'm in this
show and it's it's a long story but yeah
he thought I was a bit crazy but um yeah
it was good fun and just nice to kind of
build up the strength and stuff as so
many characters who've had to cross your
path in the show haven't we we mentioned
about sword fighting and Syrio Forel
springs to mind would you like to see
him come back and what about meeting
Jack and her gar again would you like to
meet him yeah definitely I think I've
arias met some fantastic other
characters that she's really worked well
with and then unfortunately they all get
taken away from her and we never really
know what happened what happens to them
so you know we don't know that Syria's
Syria is dead so you know that he could
come back I guess I mean I said this in
an interview a while ago and everyone on
the internet was a comic Lord he's
coming back and was like guys that was
just my opinion I don't really know that
but yeah it would be really great to
work with all these other actors again
that's that's one of the things you know
like every year you get to meet new
people but then you gotta leave your
friends behind and so yeah it was kind
of sad sometimes and the Hound her
feelings seemed to be changing towards
him don't they and Joe Dempsie is Gendry
as well he's gone - yeah I know I think
with Ari in the Hound she kind of hates
him but at the same time she's really
safe with this guy because he's got all
the things that she needs like the
respect no one's gonna mess with the
Hound so she's sort of like you know
that's a good place to be you know and
then yeah Gendry as well it kind of
seems that anyone that are at trusts
gets a gets taken away and she's really
trying like with the the yeren
relationship she kind of hooked up to
his father then he got taken away and
she really started to build up these
barriers and then he always thought you
know she's gonna look after hot buying
injury and then they leave and now she's
really kind of you know shutting
everyone else off
and it's it's kind of scary I think for
someone so young to be saying some of
the things that she is and be reacting
situation and so he she is
you